I just think that women shouldn't really
worry about cheating I think if a guy's
going to cheat he's going to cheat if
he's not he's not I don't really think
if a guy cheats that means he doesn't
love you I think men will have sex with
anything there's a reason that they have
those phrases but what you get um with
women being told they need to worry
about cheating all the time where we're
just constantly pandered to and told
them men are these dogs they're always
going to be up to nonsense as you have
women doing crazier and crazier things
to catch men cheating baiting men into
cheating and honestly I think if you
bait a guy into cheating you honestly
deserve to get cheated on sorry I know
they're going to clip that whatever
don't care